hi there this is Steve Kaufman and
welcome to our webinar today I want to
talk about motivation in language
learning which is so important as we all
know and how to maintain motivation
because this is absolutely key I think
many people start with some motivation
to learn a language and for various
reasons get frustrated and they are
unable to maintain their motivation well
in my own case I am usually quite
motivated to learn a language but it
wasn't always the case when I was 16 I
wasn't very motivated to learn languages
and I spoke one language today I speak
sixteen languages to varying degrees of
fluency but most of my professional life
I have been in business and in
particular in the lumber business and
you know what I want to compare the
undertaking if you want the enterprise
of running a business I've had my own
company for 30 years and the activity or
the undertaking of trying to learn a
language and there are similarities and
there are differences and I will talk a
bit about these you know seven or eight
years ago I was in China and I met a
Canadian there who was building homes in
China and he made this comment in China
nothing is easy but everything is
possible and he referred to the fact
that of course the business environment
in China was different from what he was
used to so he found it quite complicated
nothing is easy but in China there's
always a way to get things done he sort
of said and therefore everything is
possible but you know this expression
has kind of stuck with me because I
think it applies to a lot in life most
things that are worthwhile doing are not
easy starting a business and making a
business successful is not easy learning
a language is not easy but it's very
worthwhile and what's more it's possible
the certainly learning a language is
possible in the case of business you
know II
there are more sort of unpredictable
factors things that are outside of our
control
but I think it's very much possible it's
possible to be successful in business
it's possible to learn a language and
I'm going to talk about how if we have
tasks that are not easy but that we make
them possible this gives us a great
sense of satisfaction this has been
described in great detail in what is
known as flow theory flow-3d lling with
a task that is is a little difficult for
us not so easy but we're able to cope
with it that this is very satisfying for
us satisfying for our brain it gives us
a great sense of satisfaction it's one
of the most enjoyable things that we can
do is more enjoyable than doing easy
tasks where there's no sense of
satisfaction and of course it's more
enjoyable than attacks that frustrates
us because it's too difficult so
therefore not possible so if we can
achieve this state of flow if you know
flow like the flowing of a river flow if
we can achieve the state of law and I
suggest you google state of flow or flow
theory and you'll learn more about it if
we can get ourselves into the state of
flow then we will not only be able to
maintain our motivation in fact our
motivation will grow because we'll be
getting a sense of satisfaction and
achievement that we're coping with
something that isn't easy but that we're
making it possible to achieve and so I
think I'm gonna talk I want to focus on
how do we do this how do we get us and
get ourselves into this state of flow
and and here is where we we come to this
this issue that whatever we want to do
we have to be we have to be prepared if
I when I started my own business I I had
to be prepared I had to know something
about my market I had to know people I
had to know the product I had to be
prepared otherwise the risk was simply
too great in language learning you have
to be
paired you have to make sure you have
the materials you need maybe a starter
book in the language you should look
into resources that are available online
obviously link our site Li ng q comm but
other resources grammar resources that
are easily accessed online you have to
have the tools you have to have an mp3
player you should be familiar with how
to use iTunes you have to prepare
yourself otherwise the task isn't easy
so I think again if we want to achieve
the state of flow we want to do two
things we want to make the task as easy
as as it possibly can be and that means
being prepared and the second thing is
that we want to have a method that's
going to make things that might seem
impossible become more probable and that
means for example not trying to do
things that are too difficult to do for
example trying to memorize conjugation
tables in my experience I can't do that
now if you can do that fine but I find
that's not possible I don't think it's
possible to learn lists of words and in
fact there's considerable research that
shows that focusing on trying to learn
something like you know lists of words
that that the more time we spend on the
less we're retaining and a far more
effective way of method is to expose
yourself to lots and lots of the
language initially initially you have to
deal with rather uninteresting material
but then as soon as possible you should
move into content that's of interest and
so that you're just being exposed to the
language and and here I could go back to
this idea of preparation part of our
mental preparation has to be to
recognize that in the first few months
you're learning new words you're
learning to say things in a new language
and it's very exciting but then at some
point we realize that to achieve fluency
is a long law
Road so we need to be mentally prepared
for that but at the same time we need to
have a method of learning that enables
us to stay with the task to remain in
that state of fluid and as we get into
authentic material where we're reading
about subjects of interest to us or
watching movies that are of interest to
us so we're engaging with the language
in a way that's interesting and
satisfying it and we can introduce
variety and that's another aspect of
Methodist is to sort of very listening
and reading with possibly doing
flashcards with talking with people and
so forth so that you have a method that
makes it possible something that might
seem impossible to you like becoming
fluent in another language now becomes
possible because you have a method that
mmm enables you to stay with the task
over the long haul and if you can get
yourself in the state of floor where you
have content that's not too difficult
but it's of interest to you and your
sister eveing the sense of satisfaction
because you're able to understand it
then you're in that state of flow and
and this brings me to another point
failure
obviously in business if you fail that
could be quite dramatic and in my
business career I have had customers go
bankrupt on me and not pay me what they
owed me I've had customers suddenly
decide they no longer want to buy the
product that we've been supplying for a
long time I've had you know a number of
problems and there that consequences can
be quite dramatic in language learning a
lot of the failure is in our own minds
we think we didn't do as well as we
would have liked to we weren't able to
express ourselves as well as we would
have liked to we didn't understand as
well as we would have liked to I think
there we have to be realistic so one of
the reasons for example that I focus on
listening and reading is there's less
opportunity to fail I'm just listening
I'm reading if I don't understand I
listen again or I read and study the
words and listen
again on the other hand if I'm forced to
do tests which I don't like to do then
there's a real opportunity to get the to
fail a test to to get the wrong answer
and that's why I believe in language
learning we shouldn't give people tests
and drills and exercises but rather let
them enjoy the language so that we don't
confront them with failure and as they
build up familiarity with the language
gradually they start to speak better and
better but even with that there are
going to be moments when we don't do as
well as we would like or we feel we
don't pronounce as well as we would like
but very often these things don't really
matter
because in fact you're able to
communicate quite effectively even with
less than perfect pronunciation and with
less than perfect usage or grammar so I
think as in business we have to overcome
failure and start again very often and
there are periods when we're very
depressed because things didn't go as we
had hoped but at the same in language
there are times when you are
disappointed with your results but you
have to cope with that and again if you
focus on comprehension and accumulating
words and enjoying the language in this
state of flow you will be less upset
over your perceived shortcomings and
finally you know I think it's important
to to find people to help you in
business you can't do business without
suppliers customers friends contacts
people who help you along the way
language learning is is a little more of
an individual journey but people can be
so helpful
these can be native speakers teachers
fellow students people who can direct
you to resources on the internet where
you can find reference to whatever you
need to know it could be conjugation
tables in Italian or it could be you
know audio and text content and the
language you're learning people can help
you and you can find people to talk to
and never has it been easier to find
language companions than today
in fact never has it been easier to find
language resources than today using the
Internet and them all the different
forms of modern technology so there you
have it I just wanted to talk about this
issue of maintaining your motivation and
and really it's it's a matter of getting
yourself into a position where you can
enjoy the process of learning where
you're in this state of flow and
therefore you don't get frustrated
because once you're frustrated okay what
do you do if you're frustrated perhaps
leave it for a couple of days go back to
it study in different ways but ideally
like I don't get frustrated in my
language learning because I do things
that are enjoyable
I have realistic expectations I guess
sort of try to do things that are a
little difficult for me but not
impossible and I focus on listening and
reading to things that are enjoyable for
me and as a result my motivation grows
and I think that all of us can learn
languages in a way that sees our
motivation actually grow so that's my
sort of presentation on this issue of
maintaining motivation and we had some
technical issues in the webinar so I
have actually redone
the presentation part and now we will
switch to the the question and answer
period and I I again this webinar is
presented by link obviously as a
co-founder of Linc
I believe in link as an extremely
effective way of learning languages an
effective way of getting to interesting
and authentic content earlier so that
you aren't stuck with with what I
consider to be somewhat discouraging you
know learner material uninteresting
material where you're no longer
attracted by the interest of the content
but you're trying to force yourself to
deliberately learn something which I
don't find satisfying at all so I I
definitely recommend that you have you
know give Linc
a chance and see if it can help you and
I gather there is some special offer
access to link for a year and you'll be
seeing some information about that on
how you can take advantage of this
special offer so thank you for listening
bye for now
you
I found your mention of diffraction
theory of language acquisition to be
enlightening my language learning
experience yes I'm a great fan of
speaking crashing what would be an idea
or suggestion to keep middle-school
students motivated
well what advice would you have for
younger learners ah very good question
very difficult the my view is with
middle school students is that there
should be a greater emphasis simply on
comprehension exposing them to stories
that they can read or listen to our
movie and let emphasis on speaking
because the emphasis on speaking forces
the teacher to try to teach grammar and
do things that are panting a little bit
irrelevant to the students how do you
break the routine in your daily learning
well I kind of vary it in other words I
first of all I try do it after the
initial two three months we were forced
to listen to and read things that aren't
very interesting thereafter I focus on
things that are interesting to me and
and I find them and I'm interested in
history of interested in current affairs
I'm interested in literature I find
typically audio with the X so I can
imported it to me and then I vary
reading and listening and then when I'm
ready when I'm up for it I just speaking
I review my flashcards so I think I
think the I think the big thing is to
vary your activity you kind of
demotivating to return to a language
after years and realize you've lost a
lot of it how do you recover your
previous level I don't find it
demotivating and I find that after a
week or so of working with that language
I'm back to where I was and then I'm
actually better than I was and I guess
the point of reason is that my approach
to language learning is a major focus on
listening in
reading and so and I'm exposing myself
to I mean if I look at my experience
with Polish over the last three months I
read I don't know our statistics that
link show three hundred and fifty
thousand words I listen to you know a
hundred hours that's putting a lot of
the language into my brain now if I need
it if I leave it for three months and
I'm suddenly confronted with a Polish
person I will have difficulty speaking
however it would take me a week of
activity at length and I will be right
back to where I was if not stronger so
that's the answer there is a question
from not terrible I don't know I mean I
don't know what to tell maybe he could
add what the ten thousand in before I
comment on it
okay now let's see what we are getting
I apologize if you are if the sound
hasn't been perfect we will work on
improving it and we learn each time we
do this what would be an idea or
suggested middle school students how do
you break the root team keep them active
do you find to be motivating okay do you
have any website recommendations or
finding language partners well I use I
talkie and we have language partners
that link but very often for example in
Polish I didn't find a tutor for Polish
but in French or Spanish or English we
do have lots of tutors ethnic otherwise
I found that the I taki was good they
had I you know tried several of the
tutor propulsion that they were very
good I would say on average no okay you
talk about learning vocab rather than
using classic but I find that the idea
of only reading okay
I do flash cards but not a lot I'm very
much like doing flashcards after a
conversation so if I have a conversation
with a tutor on me
I get my conversation report there are
going to be 1520 words in there that I
didn't use correctly
those I would flash car
but otherwise I find that using link as
I'm reading any word that I've looked up
before is highlighted in yellow if it's
relevant word word that here's often in
what I'm reading about then I'll come
across it often enough but the yellow
word so I tend not to do a lot of flash
guarding I'm not convinced that but it's
a matter of what you like to do so but
personally I'm not a big fan of I don't
do a lot of so here's a question here
how can we stay motivated stick with
just one language instead of switching
all right I mean I recommend staying
with one language for a period of time
so we have our 90-day challenge for
example during that 90-day challenge I
was focused on learning polish I left
example my Korean side that's not Saylor
I didn't listen to Russian and listen to
you crane and I did but my studying
effort was focused on learning post so
yeah what can I say you just need a
little bit of discipline do you think
excessive repetition technique is
efficient to improve pronunciation
pronunciation is interesting my own deal
is that that the more we listened the
more we noticed like we may not
initially notice things in the
pronunciation of certain words are
pronounced notice intonation and so we
get better and better at some point I
think it's a good idea to record
yourself and compare yourself to the
native speaker I wouldn't do it too
often I don't see her petition as as a
big as all that helpful in pronunciation
i'ma say if I if I stopped into the
stress or despondency what do I have to
think about to motivate myself well you
know I don't know there's the stress
maybe you're creating your own stress I
study in a way that's enjoyable I listen
to things of interest I read things of
interest I don't I don't put myself in a
situation
where I'm having to answer questions or
you know fill in the word find the right
word I did mention in my videos that I
had one one polish lesson with children
i talky and she was trying to drill me
on verbs of motion and I was having to
think and find the right word and that's
stressful and I prefer not to do things
that are dreadful
I prefer to do things that are enjoyable
and I guess they're in the end
presentation on the question comparable
I didn't look at them yeah how do you
feel about the $10,000 or not yeah I
think that it doesn't apply because for
example you know if you're learning a
language that's similar to a language
you know it won't take as many hours as
if you're learning a language is very
very different so every language is
different it depends on that they have
similar the vocabulary is so polish
after Russian Ukrainian and check for me
was relatively easy Romanian which has
70 percent words that are identifiable
from Italian is relatively easy I'm fine
finding that Korean it's much more
difficult it also depends on the
resources that are available in the
language so I would say that the 10,000
hour rule has no application probably
other than the fact that it does take
time okay do you like to learn the
language to a grammar broker by
listening to music listening to music
doesn't is not going to help me learn
language I'm not a big fan of movies
either because I have to sit there and
watch the movie I mean I like watching
movie in a foreign language but or
learning I definitely prefer audio
content that I can listen to when I'm
driving when I'm exercising when I'm
doing tasks around house and reading
those to me are very word rich
environment
and most effective do you think people
had hi to link you know I would love to
add ty I would like to add Farsi I would
like to add a number of languages but we
do have certain you know conditions that
have to be met a certain range of
content that has to be available
otherwise we end up with a language with
without learning content and it can be
frustrating for people so if you can
find out you know enough enough learning
content for pi then we wouldn't
certainly add hi do you like to learn
okay do you think you are certain if my
grammar boring but which way do you find
more effective learning it's not a
matter of finding grammar boring it is
go it's ineffective to try to just sort
of nail down stuff that you're looking
at and looking at again and looking at
again you're not learning it no certain
structures of the language will will
seem natural early others will take a
long time to finally take and the best
way to get used to the grammar is to do
a lot of listening reading and you can
focus on content that will sort of zoom
in a certain aspect of the graph but you
need to see the sort of usage patterns
in use in real use over and over again
in different contexts and just studying
the rule I shouldn't say that it doesn't
do anything for you it might help you
notice those structures when you see
them in a in a real context but it's not
really interacting with the language or
you look to a great way as organizers I
hadn't thought of are there other ways
besides reading well listening is
reading that's it but to me is the 80%
of my activities that they read when you
build up your vocabulary and your
comprehension then you want to talk more
and you want to talk a lot we want to
talk a lot but I like my activities in
language learning to be meaningful and
if I can't say very much and I don't
understand the person then the
conversation I can have is not very
meaningful
okay when would you come when will you
come to Poland Slovakia check okay I
have no media plans I would love to I
tell you I would love and I would throw
in Ukraine as well since I've been
learning Ukrainian I was in Slovakia and
Czech Republic two years ago and a great
time
haven't yet been to Poland and I would
like to visit Warsaw crack all these
give hard cook yeah I would like to go
there and practice my the languages that
I've been learning I don't pay you to
take official language test to get
motivated no language to test don't
motivate me at all I don't take them
obviously I had French at school so we
had pest you know I went I study Chinese
we had a test but I don't need to take a
test no one is asking you to take a test
so I don't take tests and I don't find a
motivate I don't like being tested I
don't like being drilled on the language
I don't like answering questions
I like enjoying the language exploring
the language and so forth okay yeah I
think that's about it there I go through
this list shadowing what is the minimum
time you recommend spend time in contact
with the language predicting people who
don't have well the minimum amount of
time I think is an hour and the way you
achieve that is by doing a lot of
listening I would think if I couldn't
listen on my mp3 player I would not have
I would not have learned seven or eight
languages in the last ten years I do all
the cleanup at home cleaning up the
dishes after we eat whatever and to me
that's a 15 20 minutes of lifting time
and but the key is to have things that
you listen to that are interesting and
and where you can get access to the text
because it would be things you don't
understand so but
yeah I would say an hour a day and most
of that is gonna be listening and you
can find the listening time you know
when you're waiting in the car and so
forth
best suggestion to four tonal languages
well in terms of Chinese I have you know
I listen to these comic dialogues where
they exaggerate the tones you have to
get the rhythm of the tonal languages
trying trying to remember the tone of
each word is much more difficult have I
ever been to Turkey yes I was in Turkey
about 25 years ago I would love to go
again and and would love to learn the
language finding the time okay I think
we have it there were some mention of
shadowing I have tried it I'm not too
haven't stuck with it it's just too
difficult it's sort of to me it
interferes with my enjoyment of what I'm
listening to so I'm but you know and the
great thing about language learning is
that we can all do the things that we
find most enjoyable most motivating and
most effective they don't all have to
have the same approach okay here's a
question learning the slow and long
process you have ways to realize that
you're actually improving you know I
don't worry so much about how much I'm
improving I'm enjoying listening and
reading and I say to myself wow look at
me I think polish I now understand my
god yeah I have ways of knowing if I if
I listen to a podcast and polish a few
months ago or I understood 30% and now I
understand 80% then I'm improving and
and again my emphasis is always on
comprehension if you can really
understand what people are saying in the
language because you you have the word
because you have the sense of a language
and you can listen to it so much your
speaking will improve pretty quickly
once you have the opportunity to speak
okay
I think that's
any more questions on periscope okay
well thank you very much okay on the Ted
okay without the pillow to my webinar
from digas have you ever learned two
languages at the same time so any tips
I'm attempting especially okay I find
that I get so involved in the one
language that it's difficult to
concentrate on two languages at the same
time I may try it I might try like
Arabic and Turkish at the same time you
know it's a very difficult but I think
in terms of how our brain learn I think
it's probably a good thing in a way
because the brain needs we refresh at
some times if we're to focus on one
thing we're kind of learning less and
less so it's just a matter of how we
like to learn hey Marsha here is
attempting Spanish and French to go
further let us know how how you make out
key for you what about the similarities
in Portuguese in English I don't find
that there's a lot of similarity no no
Portuguese in Spanish yes Portuguese I
mean other than the shared
Latin origin vocabulary okay alright so
and I think so thank you very much for
listening
evil leaders well Marco explained at the
beginning there is a special offer we'd
like document those of you who one
joined us here today
then get it up we have a special offer
here is we're going to give you three
three months he gets 16 months for the
price as well talks we had a free
coaching session that stuff with
somebody can write to help you get the
most out of links so please
special offer again three three months
old fifteen months go to present well
plus a13
to the recession that is to explain and
so we all has tips and tricks that set
me even all about you to make sure work
and they will be receiving anyone on the
he's any other copy I think this is what
are we recorded yeah it's recording we
did seem to not record it for all
pendant and automate for technical
preparation I accept full responsibility
for that
but we will be booking this webinar
sending out a link to all those of you
who registered and putting it on all of
our social sites on Twitter so on so
thanks again very much for joining us
and we will see you next time
thank you provide bye